Now that we have seen semantic networks in action, we can
ask ourselves the important question. What makes a knowledge representation,
a good representation? Well, a good knowledge representation makes relationships
explicit. So in the two by one matrix problem, there were all these objects,
circles and triangles and dots. There were there this relationship between them,
left off and inside. And the semantic that worked made all of them explicit.
It exposed the natural constraints of the problem. A good representation
works at the right level of abstraction. So that it captures everything that
needs to be captured, and yet. Removes all the details that are not needed.
So representation, a good representation, is transparent, concise,
captures only what is needed, but complete, captures everything that is needed.
It is fast, because it doesn't have all the details that are not needed. And it
is computable. It allows you to draw from the inferences that need to be drawn,
in order to address the problem at hand.